Fryzel: Uh, my name is Vic.
I am today going to be
talking to you about
using the Google Docs APIs
to store all of your data
in the cloud.
Uh, so if you have any thoughts
about the talk,
or if you want to get
ahold of me after the talk,
or any--any of that, uh,
you can get a hold of me
on Twitter or Buzz,
and, uh, there's some
popular hash tags
down there at the bottom.
Actually, a lot of us,
uh, speakers this year
have been, you know,
creating Androids of ourselves,
and I think that was a bad idea,
because I think I've spawned,
like, this--
this, like, robot army
of ginger droids, uh, there--
so the first one--
watch out.
Okay, so the Google Docs APIs--
what we're gonna do is start off
with a pretty basic statement.
After I tell you about, uh,
my SpeakerMeter--
uh, so if you want to give me
feedback about the talk
or feedback about, you know,
how I spoke,
or something like that,
just take a picture
of this QR code,
um, with your device,
and then you can submit feedback
with SpeakerMeter.
Um,
so have people been using
SpeakerMeter so far?
Yes, no?
A couple people?
Uh, it's really--
really useful,
and I really appreciate
your feedback.
Um, sorry--just see some people
taking pictures.
Okay.
So.. I'm sorry?
It won't scan?
All right, just hook up
with me afterward.
Okay, so basic statement--
I think that we can all agree
that cloud storage
is really a revolution
in both the abundance
and the availability
of user data.
So nowadays, we have tons
and tons and tons of data,
and it's really
highly available,
like, we can access it
in milliseconds.
Um, so that's huge, right?
If you remember a decade ago,
we didn't have so much data,
and it wasn't as available,
so, um, even 20 years ago,
big mainframe systems,
and the data
wasn't necessarily available.
So as developers, uh,
our job is really
to, you know, assist users,
um, in some way.
Um, but it's really hard
to assist users
when the information
that you need,
um, is not readily available
via something
like an API,
so--and additionally,
you know,
users need access
to their data, too,
um, from more ways,
more locations,
and more devices.
Um, so, I mean,
you've all got tablets,
I'm sure you're accessing things
like Google Docs right now,
uh, because that's what
this talk is about.
Um, and, you know, you couldn't
do that yesterday,
um, or maybe five years ago,
or ten years ago.
Uh, so I think
what we're coming to
is the fact that, uh,
a cloud storage API
has pretty much a strong
set of requirements today,
and these requirements
seem to evolve over time,
but, uh, sharing
is really important.
I think we can all agree
that sharing data,
um, today,
is as important
as it's ever been.
Um, you should be able to easily
share your thoughts,
share your working documents,
things like that,
with other people.
Um, and then once
you've shared that data,
it's really got
to be consumable.
Um, so data should be consumable
in a useful form.
Being able to access your data
on a disk-connected device
is nice,
but also being able
to access it from
different types of applications
or from a web browser,
things like that--
in useful forms.
And then that leads, really,
into the requirement
for web UIs for applications.
Um, so web UIs are needed.
A lot of times, you know,
if a specific device application
isn't working out
or you don't have access to it,
or, um, you're on a, you know,
just a generic work station
device--things like that.
And then lastly, another
advent of the modern age
is that we have more
computing power than ever.
At Google, we have a ton
of computing power.
And so there are ways, uh,
that cloud's services can be
applied to this existing data,
um, in ways that--
that individual applications
or clients can never achieve.
So the Google Documents
List API
is just one such example,
but you might be thinking
to yourself
that the API
only stores documents,
and that's actually not true.
Um, the name
"Documents List API"
is, uh, a little bit misleading,
because the Documents List API
actually stores, uh,
all file types now,
for all accounts.
So today, I'm announcing, uh,
that arbitrary file type uploads
are now enabled in the API,
and you can now use the API for
general purpose cloud storage,
uh, for all Google users,
whereas previously,
this was only enabled for--
[applause]
Fryzel: Thank you.
Yeah, so a lot of users
in the community
have been pretty excited
about this feature.
Um, previously,
if you're unaware,
uh, this was only enabled
for Google apps
for business customers, um,
but we decided it was time
to release it for everybody.
Um, so here's just an example
of using the API
for more than just Docs.
So this is a view
of Google Docs,
um, and up here, uh,
you can see some things,
like, I've got my stocks
tracking spreadsheet,
and, you know,
my bills tracking spreadsheet,
but I've also got things like
a local backup tarball, okay?
So for you nerds out there
who like .tar.gz,
or maybe you're like, "Well, why
didn't you use a Vzip file?"
Well, you know, you can now
store all of these things
in, uh, in your Google Docs,
and I've got other things
up here,
like a recorded audio file,
a video, which I can play
in Google Docs,
uh, things like that.
And then they're organized
in a really intuitive way,
um, with collections.
So this is different
than other storage APIs,
and it's different
in a lot of ways.
Firstly, the storage
is per user,
um, and this is a very,
very significant distinction.
So users control
their storage quota, okay?
Whereas with
traditional cloud storage,
what you're doing is,
you as the developer
of an application,
are renting out space
somewhere, okay?
And then you are consuming
the user's data
and storing it somewhere.
Uh, with the Google Documents
list API,
that's different here,
where the user is giving you
their quota to use.
So the actual up-front cost
to starting developing with
the Google Documents List API,
or the Google Docs cloud,
is actually nothing, right?
Because your users already
have their storage quota,
and you just provide them
the application.
So very, very easy
to get up and running.
Uh, data is
inherently structured,
uh, within the UI,
so there are
built-in collections,
there's, uh, built-in,
um, hierarchies
in those collections,
and we're gonna talk about those
a little bit more later.
And then all entries
also have the same Metadata,
so whereas you--in a traditional
cloud storage system,
you might have to track
all of the Metadata yourself.
Here, we at Google, track
a common subset of Metadata
for each individual item.
For instance, every single item
has a title.
Um, and then lastly,
currently, uh, Documents,
in the--
in the, uh, Google Docs list
occupy zero bytes of quota.
So this might be something
that we change in the future,
but it makes it
really, really easy
for you to create
a lot of documents,
and use up zero bytes
of the user's quota.
So you get a lot for free,
with very little overhead,
using the Documents List API.
So all of those things are nice,
but the real meat of this talk
is, uh, in developing
a real working application,
so, uh, this talk
is going to be, uh,
pretty technical.
Um, we're going
to go through, um,
building something similar
to one of these other,
uh, existing real applications.
So, uh, we have spanning backup
for Google Apps.
Uh, they build a backup utility
that, uh, backs up your Docs,
contacts, and calendar
to the cloud.
Uh, syncplicity
builds a PC, Mac,
and file server syncing system,
uh, to sync files
for your enterprise.
Uh, memeo
builds memeo connects,
uh, and memeo connects
pretty much allows you
to sync, uh, your PC,
iPhone, or iPad,
um, with Google Docs.
And then lastly, we just
launched the Google Docs app
for Android, and the Google Docs
app for Android
allows you, obviously, to access
all of your documents and files
from your Android device.
So all of these
are really strong,
well-implemented solutions,
that have many, many users,
and they're already
implemented today
using the Google Documents
List API.
So this is a tried-and-true API,
um, and we have people
developing on it actively.
Um, actually, I think,
um, both Spanning Backup
and, uh, syncplicity
are here today,
so if you'd like to talk
to them, feel free to find them.
Uh, so before we go into
the deep technical parts
of the talk in developing
a real working application,
we need to take some basic
information about the APIs.
Uh, and that basic information
really comes down
to terminology.
So when you're working
with a Documents List API--
actually, who here
has worked with
a Documents List API before--
can you just raise your hand?
Okay, so maybe
a third of the room.
Uh, if you haven't yet worked
with a Documents List API,
you need to know that Document
means anything that you can edit
in Google Docs, okay?
So an example is a spreadsheet.
If you create a spreadsheet,
you can then edit that
in Google Docs,
whereas a file is considered
anything that you cannot
currently edit in Google Docs.
So if you, for instance,
uh, upload a video,
you currently cannot edit that
in Google Docs.
It doesn't mean that we won't
implement that in the future,
but, uh, right now,
it's just some arbitrary file
that you upload to the cloud,
and you don't intend
for a user to edit
from the Google Docs interface.
And then there's,
uh, a collection.
So collections, uh,
need a little bit
of an explanation.
So collections are
like two things--
they're like a folder,
and they're like a label.
They're like a folder
in the sense
that collections
have a hierarchy, right?
So folders on
a hard drive, whatever,
have a hierarchy,
so, you know,
in the root folder,
you might have, uh,
you know, My Documents, and then
My Photos, things like that,
um, whereas a label
can be applied to multiple
things at the same time.
So you can apply multiple labels
to the same objects.
So a collection is like a label
with a hierarchy.
You can put a hierarchy
within these labels,
but also a document or a file
can have, uh,
can belong to multiple
collections at the same time.
So we actually, uh, have been
doing this for quite some time,
and we realized that "folder"
wasn't really the right term,
so we started calling them
"collections,"
because they're very much more
powerful than a folder.
And then lastly, uh,
a resource is a document,
file, or collection.
So if you hear me say the word
"resource" today,
I'm just referring to one
of those three things,
because, uh, in the API,
we actually abstract out
the way you work
with these things,
so that if you wanted
to, for instance,
change the title
of a collection,
it's the same as changing
the title of a document,
so that you have
to implement less code.
So, uh, in building our
example real application,
what technologies
should we use?
Well, there's quite a few.
The first thing we're gonna do
is use OAuth,
which is open authorization,
uh, to get a user's permission
to access their documents list.
So really quick, I just wanted
to discuss the difference
between authentication
and authorization.
Authentication is, uh,
the mechanism
of identifying a user,
whereas authorization
is the mechanism
of getting that user's
permission to do something,
okay?
So authentication happens when
you browse through Gmail.com,
and have to enter
your username and password.
Authorization happens
when Google asks you,
"Would you like to allow
this application
to access your Google Docs?"
okay?
So those are two
very distinct terms,
and people sometimes
mix them up.
Here we're talking
about authorization only.
We're not gonna worry about
any usernames or passwords.
Um, so when we implement OAuth,
this is essentially a mechanism
for us to get a user's
permission to access their Docs,
and then do so with a token.
We're going to use App Engine
to host the application.
You could obviously
host the application
on any provider you'd like,
including your own servers,
um, but it's really easy to get
an application up and running
in a short amount of time
in App Engine,
so I'm going to just by chance
use App Engine today.
We're also gonna use
JavaScript and HTML5,
uh, to give a useable interface.
Like I said,
this is a real application,
so we're gonna implement
the full thing,
from the App Engine app,
to OAuth,
to--all the way up
to the user interface.
Um, so there's a whole bunch
of other talks
on JavaScript and HTML5.
The things that I'm going to do
are not nearly as advanced
as some of the things
in the other talks,
and I recommend you attend those
if you're more interested
in these topics.
And then, of course, we're gonna
use the Documents List API
to manage most of the data.
Um, if your data
has a custom schema,
I highly recommend you use
the spreadsheets API,
so the way this would work is if
you needed, like, custom fields,
you would use
the Documents List API
to create a hidden spreadsheet
in the user's account,
and then you would use
the spreadsheet's API
to manipulate the data
in that spreadsheet
and store arbitrary data
for your application--
all within the user's control.
So what does
the application do?
Let's take a quick look.
So, um,
I've got this application
running on a local host,
:8080,
um, and it's just because I have
the local App Engine
instance running.
So if I browse here,
I'm immediately taken
to the Google accounts page,
um, asking me to grant access
to this application, uh,
for my Google Docs.
So the application
is immediately sending me here,
uh, just to click grant access,
essentially,
saying, yes, allow this
application access.
And when I click "grant access,"
I'm taken to the application.
So let me go
to full screen here.
So here's the application.
Uh, it's called Categorical.ly.
I'm sorry, I couldn't think
of a better web 2.0 bad name.
Uh, so the purpose
of the application
is to allow us
to easily, uh, update
our Google Documents list
with files from our desktop.
So here, I have a folder
with some stuff in it.
Here's an image I took
at Half Moon Bay,
which is here in California.
Here's another image of some
berries on a tree, I think.
And then, uh,
I have a zip file
of both of these images.
So my goal here, really,
is to easily get these,
uh, into Google Docs
from our sample application.
So the whole purpose of this
is to be able to, uh,
drag one file from our, um,
from our, uh, finder,
and into a collection,
uh, here,
in our Google Docs.
So let's see--
I'll drag this to my book--
I'm not really writing a book.
I just created that folder.
And so that's it--
The application refreshes,
we're done.
So where did the file go?
Well, if I pull up Google Docs--
and I think I called it
Archive.zip.
If I search for this,
here it is,
and it's in
the correct collection,
so let me zoom in here
so you can see this.
So I actually uploaded it
to the My Book collection,
and here it is on top.
I've actually uploaded
this file before, to test,
so that's why it exists twice.
But, uh, My Book,
and then if I click on this,
you'll notice that this
is an example of a file,
and I cannot currently edit
zip files in Google Docs.
So here, I'm taken
to a more generic page
that describes some information
about this file.
Um, for instance, like,
which collections it's in,
or what size it is--
it allows me to download it from
the web UI--things like that.
So, uh, everybody understands
the general purpose
of this application
is just to make it really easy
to drag and drop files
from the desktop to here.
Um, so how did we
implement this?
This seems like a really
simple application,
and there are a lot of parts,
but I'm going
to go through today
and show you just exactly
how all of this works together.
So, um, when we walk
through the source code today,
we're gonna walk through it
in a couple of steps.
First, I'm gonna go through how
to create an App Engine app--
specifically, a Python
App Engine app,
but you could do
all of this in Java.
Um, then I'm going to implement
3-legged OAuth,
and when I implement
that's gonna take a little bit
of explaining,
because we have to do this thing
called the OAuth dance.
Uh, we're going to implement
a JavaScript,
an HTML5 user interface,
and then lastly, we're gonna use
the Documents List API
to manage everything.
So this is, uh,
this whole application
comes out to be about 375 lines
of actual code.
Um, so if you'd like
to follow along
from your laptop,
uh, or at home,
you can just follow
this Google link
to the source code
for this entire application,
which is all open source.
Uh, so that's just, uh, NAkZM.
So let's take a look
at the source code.
Um, here first,
I have this App Engine app
set up
so that, uh, you know,
I have a ReadMe file,
and I have an app.yaml file,
things like that.
Uh, these are basic
App Engine appliances,
and I'm not gonna go through
those specifically today,
because there are separate talks
about App Engine.
What I am going
to go through, though,
is the app called
G Categorical.ly,
and so here's all of the source
code for G Categorical.ly.
So you can--if you're familiar
with Python,
uh, here, we have an init
up high,
which is pretty basic for
declaring a Python module.
And then, uh, the handlers
are the important bits
of information here.
Um, so you can see,
we have an OAuth handler
to handle the OAuth portion
of the application,
a collection handler to handle,
um, you know,
manipulating collections,
pulling down the list of
collections, things like that.
And then we have
a default handler,
and all this really does
is render the main page.
Um, it's a little bit difficult
to see on the screen here,
but there's a directory
over here called "Static,"
and a directory over here
called "Templates."
So Static just includes all of
our JavaScript and CSS files,
and then Templates
just includes an index
of that HTML file, which we use
to render the main page.
So let's start by taking a look
at default handler.
And--anyway--
so, uh, here,
pretty basic stuff.
This is just a license
declaration, author--
none of that's
really important.
Down here is where we actually
get to the meat of the code.
So, um, since this
is an App Engine application,
the way uploading files works
is with a blobstore handler,
so you can think of a blob
as just some arbitrary
blob of bytes,
and a blobstore upload handler
just handles uploads
of these bytes,
stores them somewhere
temporarily,
waits for the application
to, uh, you know,
use them in some way,
and then you can just delete
the--the temporary file.
Um, so again, with App Engine,
we create a handler,
and then we define methods
based on the HTTP, uh,
request method we're using.
So there are a number
of different HTTP,
uh, request types--
we have, like, uh,
Get, Put, Post, and Delete.
Those are the main ones
for a restful API.
Um, and here, it's just really
easy to implement Get and Post,
so when we run a Get request,
uh, to the default handler,
we're going to do
a couple of things.
Our goal is to generally--
or, to, uh, generally render
the main page,
but we have a couple
of subgoals in here.
We're going to create
an OAuth token handler,
and then get
an authorized client.
All this really allows us to do
is say,
"Give me some abstract object
that is authorized to work
with the Google
Documents List API," okay?
So it's just
those two lines of code.
If a client comes back
as "none,"
then we need
to authorize, okay?
So just redirect the user
to the authorization page.
But if it doesn't come back
as "none," continue.
Uh, give the template
index.html,
uh, an upload URL,
where the user can upload
their files,
and then, uh, render
that template
to the screen, essentially.
Um, post is, uh,
has a different goal.
Its goal is to receive a file
from the user,
and then send it away
to Google Docs
in the appropriate
collection, okay?
So again, when they come in,
OAuth token handler,
get authorized client--
um, so these two things
are just, you know, again,
doing the authorization steps.
We're getting the parent,
which is the parameter being
passed in from the client.
Uh, this is just telling us
where the user
wants the file to go, okay?
So the parent is just going
to be the resource identifier
of a collection.
Then the URI we want to post to,
uh, is documented
in the Google Documents List API
documentation.
Um, essentially here,
this is something--
some predefined URL
with which we can, uh,
upload documents and files
to a particular collection.
And you can see here,
I do string substitution
to replace the parent
that they gave us,
um, into the URL,
and you can see up here,
this is secure,
because I do a "regex replace,"
uh, for malicious characters.
So, uh, down here, uh,
I'm going to get the files
uploaded from the user,
and for each file,
uh, if the client is "none,"
then we need to authorize, okay?
So back up here, if we got
no client that was authorized,
then we need to send the user
to the authorization page.
Does that make sense?
So then we're going to use
this utility class
called "resumable uploader,"
and this allows us
to do a lot of things.
in bandwidth-constrained
environments,
uh, you usually want to use
a resumable uploader,
because what that
allows you to do
is send the file off in chunks,
and that's very important.
So if you're working,
for instance, on a phone,
and you have
a very limited connection,
or limited bandwidth,
I highly recommend you use
resumable uploader,
because now you can split your,
for instance,
10-megabyte file
into chunks of 256k,
and send those chunks
individually.
If the individual chunk fails,
you can resume from that point,
uh, so very, very useful
to use the resumable uploader.
It's also required to upload
files in the Documents List API,
but you may as well just
use it for everything,
because we have future plans
to just make it the default.
Um, here, we're creating
a Documents List entry.
This is just a wrapper class
that has some basic things
like a title in it,
so here, you can actually see me
set the title to the file name
of the file being uploaded.
So in the demonstration before,
you saw me upload Archives.zip,
and the title of the file
was actually made
to be "Archives.zip."
Lastly, I'm saying
to the helper class
to upload the actual file, uh,
to the Google
Documents List API.
Um, down here,
this blobinfo.delete--
that just deletes
the temporary file,
because when you upload a file
from the client side
to a web server,
it has to store it somewhere.
So we're just deleting
the temporary file
and doing good housekeeping.
After that, we're redirecting
to the main page,
so after they drop the file,
we're just redirecting
the main page,
showing the user interface
again,
and they can upload more files
if they wish.
Um, so that's pretty much it.
The rest of this file is just
going to create
a WSGI application.
Um, if you're not
familiar with this,
just read the App Engine
Python documentation.
Um, setting this up is part
of the Hello World project.
Um, this is just a basic way
to interface
that handler that we just wrote
with, uh,
App Engine's interpreters.
So that's pretty much it
for the default handler,
and that handles displaying
the main page,
and receiving files.
But we kind of skipped over
a lot of stuff.
Um, one major thing
that we skipped over
was all of that OAuth logic.
So the way OAuth works,
essentially,
is you have to,
when a user, uh,
comes to you unauthorized,
you have to generate
a request token,
and then send that user
off to Google,
or off to the OAuth
service provider--
identity provider, excuse me.
So the OAuth identity provider
is the pers--
or the entity who's
going to say, "Yes,
"this user is legitimate,
and, yes, this user
gives your application
permission to do something."
So in this particular case,
the identity provider
is, uh, Google,
so what we want to do
is redirect the user to Google
with a request token.
Google will allow the user
to click, uh, you know,
allow access,
and then the application
will redirect the user back
to our application with
a special parameter in the URL,
Okay? That special parameter
is an authorized request token,
and then our application
is going to take
that authorized request token
and turn it
into an access token.
All of this is--I agree with
you--a little bit complicated.
That's why we write
sample applications,
and you copy and paste.
So what we're doing here
is we're creating
a new OAuth token handler, um,
we're creating new client.
Here, remember I used the term
"request token.
So we're just getting
a request token,
and then we're generating
a callback URL.
This just says, "Hey, Google,
after you're done
authorizing the user, uh,
send them back to this spot,"
so that allows the user
to be bounced around
in their browser
pretty seamlessly.
Um, so here, uh, we're getting
a request token,
and we're storing it temporarily
while we send the user
off to Google.
Because when they come back,
they're gonna have
an authorized request token,
and we need to be able
to look them up somehow.
Um, after we
store it temporarily,
here's the redirect,
uh, request,
and the authorization URL,
and then once they come back,
uh, there's an authorized
request token,
and we're going to upgrade that
to an access token,
so this access token
is what allows us
to make requests via the API.
So your application
will store this access token,
uh, for an indefinite
period of time,
and then use it
to make requests
that, you know, to perform your
application's basic functions.
What's important about this
is that a user
can revoke this token,
and what that means is,
they can pretty much stop
allowing your application
to access their data
for a number of reasons.
Um, and if they revoke
this token,
the access token will
no longer work with the API.
You'll get a 401
unauthorized error,
um, when this returns.
So that's actually handled
in some other logic
in this file, but that's
not really relevant.
Um, this is just handling
the OAuth dance,
and that's the important part.
And the stuff up here is just,
uh, used for basic
key management.
It's important to note
that here, I'm using
the Documents List API scope,
so the token I get back
is scoped, uh,
for the scopes that you request.
So here, I'm requesting
docs.google.com/feeds--
uh, that's the base URL of
the Google Documents List API.
And when this scope comes
into the authorization logic,
on Google's end, what we do is,
uh, look at these scopes,
and then determine what we have
to ask the user permission for.
So in this particular case,
it's Google Docs.
Um, if this said something
like "contacts" in the URL,
then the user would see,
you know,
this application wants
to access your contacts.
So, uh, that's pretty much it
for the OAuth logic.
I highly recommend you just
come in here and copy exactly
what I did, and not try
to implement this yourself,
uh, because this is kind of
a pain to get working.
Um,
so that's the OAuth handler,
and then the last part,
uh, starts to work with
the Documents List API.
Um, so working with
the Documents List API,
uh, there are a number
of best practices,
and a lot of those are exposed
here in the collection handler.
So you'll remember,
we have two general goals--
uh, the first is to show
the user a page
in which all of their
collections are available,
uh, in a tree form,
and the second goal is to,
uh, be able to upload a file
to one of those collections.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is look at this tree generation.
So, uh, what we can do
with the collection handler
is, uh, look at something
like the generate
collections tree method.
So what this does
is it turns a flat
representation of a tree
into a, uh, hierarchical
representation of a tree.
So the Documents List API,
when you make a request,
sends back collections
in a flat list,
so the, uh, root collection
may be at the same--
the same place in the list
as, uh, you know,
the My Book collection,
or the, uh, Photos collection,
something like that.
So you've just got
this flat list--
everything's the same level.
Here, we use
a recursive traversal
to turn this into a tree,
uh, that we can later walk
to show something on the screen.
So for instance, uh, when
we show this to the screen,
we need to be able to
recursively generate this,
right? Because, for instance,
here, protagonists
is a subcollection of My Book.
It's a subcollection of Home.
So when we walk through this,
we're actually creating
a new element for each
individual child,
and then we're creating
the element for the parent,
and so on, uh,
walking back up the tree.
So let me go back.
So this is just a recursive--
a recursive call to do this.
You can see here,
parent.subcollections.append,
and then I actually called
the same method name again,
um, to generate the sub-tree
of those collections.
Um, there are some other
helper methods in here,
but they're not really,
uh, that important
if you read through them,
they're obvious in function.
So before I call the method
to generate the tree,
what I'm going to do is
say "Collections equals"--
Remember, our authorized
client is here--
".GetDocList,"
so this is just a helper method
to make some HTTP requests
and pull down, um,
a list of resources
from the API.
So here,
"feeds default private full"--
you can ignore all of that.
Uh, hyphen, folder--
This says, "Give me all of--
all of the folders,
"or all of the collections
from the Documents List API,
so that I can do something
with them."
Uh, there's an important
parameter here
called "showroot equals true,"
so by default,
uh, collections in Google Docs,
uh, exist with, uh,
no understanding
of a root collection, okay?
So there's not, like,
a root collection
that a user can go delete,
right?
Because if they deleted
the root collection,
that would be awkward, right?
Um, so we don't expose that
in the API.
We don't say,
"Here's a root collection
that you can manipulate
just like other collections."
You can't delete this,
so we don't even show it.
Um, it's just assumed to exist,
uh, so here,
when we say
"show root equals true,"
what we're actually
doing is saying, um,
for all of
the other collections, uh,
give them a special label
if they are in root, okay?
So we still don't give you back
a root collection,
but we say
for all of the other ones,
if they happen to be at the top
level, say so, okay?
Um, and then here, uh,
for I.N. range collections,
we're just iterating
through the number of--
or, through each collection--
we're generating
the collections tree, and, uh,
you know, turning that
into a JSON form.
So this Get request
is actually gonna be used
via AJAX,
and we're going to say,
you know, to JavaScript,
"Here's a JSON
tree representation
"of all of the collections
in this user's documents list.
"Now it's up to you, JavaScript,
to turn that
into a user interface, okay?"
So this is server-side logic.
We're doing the tree generation,
server-side,
and then the client
is receiving that
and turning that
into a UI representation.
And then here,
you can see that we set
the content type of the response
to text/JSON,
and we write out, uh, the tree.
So that was collection handler.
Let's go back to the UI
and review everything
that's happening.
Uh, default handler
is generating this page.
By default, though,
if I refresh, for instance--
Whoops. Sorry, killed
my App Engine app.
Whoops.
So let me just
start this back up.
Here. See? App Engine
is as simple as that.
Here, you can see
the title loads first.
Why does that happen?
There's a slight delay.
Let's look again. Title
loads first, then the rest.
It's because
the title loads first
as part of the base template,
and then an AJAX request is
being made to collections.JSON,
that--that method
that we just looked at,
um, to fetch this and then
generate it in the UI, okay?
So why do we do it this way?
There are a couple
of good reasons.
Firstly, uh, in general,
for large numbers of objects,
you don't want to do tree
generation client-side, okay?
You don't want to iterate
a very, very large number
of objects or do some recursive
generation in the browser.
You would much rather
do that server-side,
cache it, and then send it
to the browser, right?
Because, you know,
our thousands of servers
are frankly faster
than your MacBook Arrow.
So, uh, let us do
the tree generation,
and then, uh,
we'll just send it off
to the client already generated,
and then it just creates
a much faster experience,
uh, for the user.
It also allows us to do things
like caching, uh, server-side,
so we can just spit out
the response
without even bothering
to go re-fetch
the whole collections list.
And then we can do things like
cache expiration detection,
where we just pull the Documents
List and look for a change,
and if there's a change,
we'll expire the cache
and then re-fetch.
Um, so all of that should be
transparent to the user.
So again, that's why you get
this delay here
between the title and this,
and then what we could do is,
for instance, cache this
browser-side, uh, you know,
with local storage in HTML5.
So, uh, what else
is going on here?
Um, when we drop a file on,
something has to happen, right?
There must be code in the world
that handles
this file drop action,
um, and we haven't
looked at it yet,
so let's take a look at it now.
Firstly, in Chrome, if you go to
"inspect element" on anything,
you'll see
a whole bunch of stuff
that we don't really care about,
and then you'll see this
"input type equals file."
Let me see if I can
zoom in here. Whoops.
So "input type equals file,"
uh, "name equals files,"
"multiple class equals file."
Okay? So the word "file"
is probably used
too many times there.
Um, but essentially,
its type is "file,"
so an input type of file means,
uh, you can browse for a file,
uh, select it, and then
click "upload" later on.
And then its name is "files,"
uh, so here, we're just saying
we're going to accept
multiple files, um,
at--to be dropped at once.
So I could grab
all of my photos,
drop them on--on a collection,
and then just--boom,
they all get uploaded.
And then, uh,
"class equals file"--
this is important
for a different reason.
So you don't see an "upload"
button here at all, right?
So what we're doing is something
very, very sneaky.
Uh, we are on this file object,
setting its opacity to 0,
and its position to absolute,
and then making it 100%
width and height.
So what we're actually doing
is hiding the button,
and then we're expanding
the whole thing,
uh, to fill this entire cell,
so that if you drop
anywhere on this,
we'll receive a drop action
on this, uh, file input.
Once we receive the drop action
in JavaScript, we can--
you know, we can work with it.
So let's take a look
at the actual JavaScript
that does this.
Let me go to
G Categorical.ly again,
and static/js.
base.js.
Okay, so more code.
Whole bunch of stuff
is going on here.
Uh, most of it is irrelevant.
Um, "refresh collections"--
all this really does
is, uh, generates a--
actually,
it takes a collection tree
that was generated server-side,
and it renders it to the screen.
So here, you can see
"render collection tree,"
so let's find
render collection tree.
So here's the method.
So you can see, a whole
lot of stuff is going on.
Um, all this really does
is generate some HTML elements,
and then put them into
the--into the DOM, okay?
So, uh, we're creating
a new cell,
a cell being the thing
that contains the collection,
like, uh, My Book,
and then this is a div element,
so basic HTML here,
and we're giving it
a special CSS class, okay?
And then we're appending a form,
and we're giving the form
some parameters.
Then we're appending a label
and a couple of input fields.
So all of these are important.
The input field here
is called "parent."
Remember, we have to say
where this file should go
when you drop it?
Uh, so "parent" here
is the resource identifier
of this individual collection,
which is some, uh,
arbitrary string
of characters, uh,
just to identify
this particular collection.
Uh, here, we have
a "submit" button.
We're going to hide this
in the UI,
because the user should never
have to click "submit."
This is, like, the web 2.0 era,
so submit buttons
are so obsolete.
And then we have the, uh,
file input that we
just took a look at.
Um, and here, we're setting
those attributes
that we--that we just saw.
So let me go back
to the browser.
Remember, um, these attributes,
so we have, uh,
"input type equals submit,"
"input type equals file."
Those are actually generated,
uh, right here.
So "input type equals submit,"
"input type equals file."
So in JavaScript, we're just
dynamically generating
these elements, and then we
are appending them to the DOM.
And then lastly, on this--
on this, uh, on this form input,
we are--sorry, I misspoke--
on this file input--this one--
what we are doing is binding it
to a change event,
so the change event means,
like, somebody
dropped a file on here,
and then we're calling
the click method
on the submit button.
So web 2.0 era--
we can click buttons for users.
So here,
we're just calling click
on the submit button
that we created right here,
uh, as soon as somebody drops
one or more files
onto the input.
Um, and then that's it.
So, uh, that's how we're
handling the drop event.
So again, if I come back here,
essentially,
the use case is,
I take a file,
I drop it on a collection,
so, My Books,
and then the upload happens.
So when that happened,
we're sending--
we're just submitting the form--
the hidden form.
The hidden form
is submitting off, uh,
to the URL that
we provided earlier,
and then we automatically
get, uh, rerouted back
to the main page after
the file has been uploaded,
and then the file shows up
something like this.
Um, so that's--
that's a pretty basic
introduction
to what this code does,
but again,
if you walk through it,
we just have a--
a couple of different things
to manage,
and most of the code
is marshaling data
between, uh, two handlers.
It's a lot of helper methods.
The meat of the application is
actually only a couple of lines
of important things.
So let's go back
to the presentation,
if I can find that.
And let me go full screen.
Whoops.
Okay, so let's go through
some best practices,
because you're
all here to learn, uh,
deep details on how to use
the API best.
Firstly, use resumable upload
for everything.
It's only a good thing,
and it's very easy to use.
There's no barriers entry, um,
and it allows you to use
the application
in more environments
on more devices.
Uh, you should fetch
as many resources as possible
in a single request.
Um, why--why is this good?
Well, firstly, there's, uh,
there's a round-trip time
for any HTTP request.
I mean, we're Google. We serve
things really, really quickly.
But, uh, there are networks in
between that don't go so fast,
and so you want to reduce
the number of requests you make
as much as possible,
so for instance,
I want to pull all of the fold--
or all of the collections
in a single request,
and then manipulate them, okay?
I don't want to pull them
in multiple requests, uh,
and have to, like,
just load up my list
and then manipulate them.
That's a longer process.
You should, uh, cache
each resource individually,
so with the Documents List API,
you get a list
of resources back.
Each one should be
cached individually
so that you can expire caches
on an individual
resource basis, okay?
So if one resource changes,
why would you re-fetch
all of the other resources?
That doesn't make any sense.
so cache each resource
individually,
and you will drastically improve
the performance
of your application.
Uh, I've already said
perform collection tree
generation server-side,
and then, uh, cache
the collection trees
and their contents
server-side, as well,
so that you're just sending
down to the client
the processed data,
so the client doesn't
have to do anything
on their end,
especially if they have a device
with not a lot of power.
Um, if you're
implementing something
like a synchronization client,
each resource has this field
called "app:edited,"
and what that means is,
when that date changes,
uh, it implies that the user
has made some change
to the resource.
So for instance,
if we take the, uh,
example of a text document,
if the app edited date changes
and your application notices,
that would indicate that
the user has logged in
to the Google Docs user
interface and changed something
in the document,
so that something could be,
you know, they bolded this word,
or they inserted this image--
uh, anything.
Um, some more best practices--
um, when sharing,
uh, resources
with the Documents List API,
you can share with a key,
and this is like
"a top-secret password,"
uh, that gets appended to a URL.
And then everybody you give
that URL to
can now, uh, access
the document,
so it's not really
that top-secret,
because people can
just share the link,
but it essentially restricts
access based on having a link.
So, uh, one question
that I get a lot is,
"How do you set the initial key,
uh, for this URL?"
And the answer is, uh,
you can't set the key.
We just generate one for you.
So when you set the initial key,
it's going to automatically
be overridden, so you could put
like, my super-secret password
in there,
and we're just gonna
throw that out
and use something
a little bit more secure
than my super password, right?
Um, also, uh, access control
list requests.
So essentially,
sharing requests,
uh, should be batched together
as much as possible.
If you have
an enterprise domain,
and you're trying to share
something with 1,000
out of 8,000
of your employees,
you should batch those requests,
those individual share requests,
uh, into single requests,
uh, into a single request
to the Documents List API,
right?
Um, so why send 8,000 requests
to the API when you
can send one, right?
Remember, a smaller number
of requests is better.
Um, also, to share
a large number of items
at once like that,
it's actually best
to put them all in a collection,
and then just share
the collection.
And if you share a collection,
that will give view access
to everything in the collection
by default,
um, for every user
that you share it with.
Um, we've also added
some features recently
that allow you to easily back up
employees' Documents List
using admin access
on your Google Apps,
uh, for Business domain, okay?
Um, so I'm not sure
how many people here
work in the enterprise setting?
So you develop apps
for your company.
Uh, this is actually
important for you.
Um, if you have a company--
or, I misspoke--
if you have, for instance,
leave the company
and you need to do some sort of
discovery on all of their Docs,
or something like that,
a Google apps administrator only
can access this
and impersonate that user
just to do a backup,
okay?
So that just eases
a lot of hassles with, uh,
Google Apps domains.
Uh, my final best practice,
uh, is to use OAuth
whenever possible,
without exception.
So if you have a choice
between using OAuth,
AuthSub, client login,
definitely use OAuth,
even if you're writing
an application that is, uh,
installed on a server, okay?
So for an application that's
installed on a server, uh,
where you can't, for instance,
uh, you know,
show a browser
and then authorize,
you know, this token,
what you should do is,
if you don't have a Google apps
for business domain,
in which you can use
2-legged OAuth,
that means you have to use
3-legged OAuth,
and these terms again, are
discussed in other talks here,
but 3-legged OAuth can be done
using a stored token.
So what you would do
is, in a web browser,
run through once and authorize
a single token,
and then you would essentially
paste that token
into your script
or into your program
that's going to run
on the server,
and now that program can make
authorized requests
indefinitely, okay?
So no web browser involved.
That's kind of a way
to circumvent the need
for 2-legged OAuth,
which skips the browser.
Okay, so, you know, in closing,
you should definitely
be considering
the Documents List API
for any of your cloud storage,
especially because
it's free to use,
and your users are going
to pay for the quota, okay?
Actually, not even pay. We're
just going to give it to them.
Um, so this is
a much better solution
than some other options,
and additionally,
you get things like
a built-in web interface, uh,
for all of these items,
built-in sharing,
and built-in
resource management,
um, from the user's end.
So just for some more resources,
you can take a look
at the documentation,
which has a Google link there.
Um, and also the forum,
so if you have a question,
and you, for some reason,
cannot find me
on the internet,
uh, you can post in the forum,
and myself or one of our very
small team will respond to you.
I mean, I was responding
to posts on the forum
at, like, 4:00 a.m.
this morning, okay?
I'm dedicated, right?
So, uh, then also the code
for the sample application
is right there.
And, uh, I just wanted
to give a quick thanks, uh,
to a couple members
of the team.
That would be Rob, Russ, Ivan,
and the rest
of the Google Docs team.
Uh, so I feel pretty passionate
about this product,
and you should, too,
because a whole lot of good,
good work goes
into this product.
When I look at where we were,
for instance, four years ago
versus today, it's just
night and day different,
and now we're providing
a really stable,
uh, sustainable API
for your consumption.
So a great thanks goes out
to those guys,
who do a lot of great work.
Um, lastly, if you wanted to
tweet or buzz about this talk,
you can use these hash tags
down here,
and if you want to give me
feedback, again,
please use SpeakerMeter.
The QR code is here.
Um, so that's it.
Thank you very much for
your time. I appreciate it.
[applause]
Fryzel: So I just wanted to take
questions at the microphones,
please.
Hmm?
Oh, yeah, let me get back
to the previous.
Did you have a question?
man: Yeah. Hey, how's it going?
Uh, thanks, great talk.
I've been using Google Docs
for a couple years, um, the API.
Fryzel: Okay.
man: I guess I've implemented
something using Google Docs
on--in, I guess, in the cloud,
and it's great,
and I think there's other
opportunities to maybe do,
like, there would
be opportunities
for me to port the solution
I did in the cloud, and then,
like, a closed enterprise
environment, if, like, uh,
Google Docs appliance
was something that existed,
and I guess I was wondering
if that's ever been
on the road map?
Fryzel: Uh, at this time,
I'm unaware
of a Google Docs appliance,
unfortunately.
Um, however, in
an enterprise setting, uh,
you can actually do a lot
of things to restrict access,
uh, to Google Docs.
For instance, you could
implement SAML single sign-on,
and then put the single sign-on
page behind a firewall
in your organization,
and that would actually restrict
a lot of access, uh,
to things like Google Docs,
because now as the single
sign-on provider,
you're telling us
who is authenticated,
uh, and because of that reason,
if the user cannot access
the authentication page
where they enter
their username and password,
they can't log in.
So if you'd like
to talk to me after,
I can tell you
how to implement that.
man: Yeah, I'll--cool, thanks.
Fryzel: Yeah, yeah. Hello.
man: Hi, thanks for the talk.
Um, I was wondering
if there's--with a--
it's a Google Docs API question
in general,
um, in requesting a resource,
or entities from
a specific collection,
is there a way
to only ask for, uh, items
within that collection
that have--
only those items in the
collection that have changed?
Say, a request, you know...
Fryzel: Yes.
man: From a specific folder,
and it gives me everything
in that folder,
um, but, I mean,
I only want the things in that
folder that have changed?
Fryzel: It's funny you would
ask that question to me,
because my answer to you
is that--uh, not yet.
man: Okay. [laughs]
That would be nice.
Fryzel: That's something we're
definitely considering, though.
man: Okay, thank you.
Fryzel: Yeah.
Hello.
man: Hi. My question is, um,
you said if you wanted
to store, like,
your own document types
in there,
like, use a spreadsheet API,
or anything like that--
is there any way
that there will ever be
a way to where you register
your own file types
through the Google Docs
interface,
it would launch out to your app,
or do you really have to do
like you did,
and put your own face
on top of it,
and really just use Docs
for storage?
Fryzel: Also a very
interesting question.
Uh, that is something
we are considering.
man: Okay.
Fryzel: Yeah.
man: Hi. So you mentioned
that administrators
can impersonate an employee,
which is something
that our company,
as a Google Docs user,
is very interested in--
employees who leave--we want
to make sure we can get access
to their documents--
can we only back up a list
of their documents,
or can we actually back up
the contents of each document?
Fryzel: Actually, you can
fully impersonate the user,
so anything else
you could do in the API,
you could do, uh,
while impersonating them,
as a--using a Google Apps
admin account.
Um, yeah.
man: Great.
Fryzel: Yeah. Hi.
man: Hi. Is there a, uh,
like, a high-level
G Docs API in the And--
I'm building an Android
mobile phone app
that I want to upload a file
in the Android application
into the user's G Docs...
Fryzel: To a user's G Docs.
man: GMAIL account--is there
kind of like a high level, or...
Fryzel: So, uh, can you describe
your ideal outcome?
Would it be an e-mail
in their inbox with the file?
man: No, we would like
to just have, like a button,
and then an API that
we would take our file,
and then just--
it ends up in the G Docs user--
Fryzel: Oh, the Google
Documents List--
um, this API
can do that for you.
man: This one?
Fryzel: Uh, even from
an Android device.
So, uh, the API itself,
at its core,
is an HTTP RESTful API,
so you send off, essentially,
web requests to do stuff.
Um, however, we implement,
uh, a Java client library,
a Python client library,
um, a .NET client library,
and a PHP client library,
and the Java client library
is ideal for your use case,
because you would take
the Java client,
drop it into an Android app,
and then you could just, uh,
you know--
you'd probably register
an intent, or something,
to, uh, you know, just send
the file off to Google Docs.
But, yeah, totally possible,
and, in fact, I mean,
we did it, with the Google Docs
app for Android.
man: Sure. Okay, thank you.
Fryzel: Yeah, pleasure.
Hello.
man: Hi. Um, is there
any way to--
Fryzel: I'm sorry, I can't
hear you. Can you come closer?
man: Hi. Can you hear me now?
Hello?
Can you hear me now?
Fryzel: Yes.
man: Okay, sorry.
Um, I was wondering,
is there a way to implement
version history
when uploading files?
Fryzel: Yes, we have full
revision history support.
You can create, retrieve,
update, and delete revisions
with the API today.
Um, if you're interested
in seeing how to do that,
just let me know.
man: Okay.
Fryzel: Um, but you can do
arbitrary file revisioning
of anything that you upload.
man: Okay.
Fryzel: You can also consume
revisions from, uh, documents,
so for instance,
in a text document,
uh, as you're typing away,
if there's, like,
a conflict or something,
and you need to, uh, you know,
fork a new revision,
you can access those
in the API today.
man: Okay, thank you.
Fryzel: Sure.
Hi.
man: Hi there, and I'm sorry
if this question was answered--
I missed the first half
of your talk--
Um, what's the supportability,
SLI, backwards compatibility,
API story for this stuff?
Fryzel: I'm sorry,
I still can't hear you--
Can you come closer to the mic?
man: Sure. Yeah, I guess
the microphone's, uh--
it's very loud right here--
um, so the question was,
uh, given--
what is the supportability,
SLI, backwards compatibility,
deprecation, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera, story
for these APIs?
We've done an integration
with our application
with Google Docs,
and we've had great trouble
with APIs changing
unexpectedly over time--
now a lot of this work was done
8 months to 2 years ago,
so maybe things have stabilized,
but I know we were trying to get
some information from Google
about just
backwards compatibility
and deprecation changes.
Can we be--can we rely
on the API for a period of time?
Fryzel: Yeah.
man: Do we need to be--
is there a blog,
is there an RSS feed
we should monitor?
Fryzel: Uh, there is a blog--
it's called the Google apps
developer blog, uh,
that will tell you
essentially all changes
that happen with the API.
There's also an RSS feed
in the documentation,
uh, called release notes,
and that tells you any changes
that we make.
Um, I also wanted to point out
that sometimes
my purpose in life is to make
sure that things don't change
so that you don't have to
reimplement your application,
and I--
I mean, really, sometimes
I think I take it too far.
So, uh, we try really,
really, really hard
not to change something,
but there are
particular circumstances
in which we cannot avoid, uh,
breaking backwards compatibility
that we feel for the--
our users' benefit,
we must implement.
Uh, and those are really
the only occasions
in which we will break
backwards compatibility.
Um, that said,
our out-of-labs APIs,
uh, have a 3-year
deprecation policy,
in which, uh,
if we are going to,
uh, break
backwards compatibility
for, um,
for a non-important reason,
we have to give you
three year's notice, okay?
man: And are these APIs
in the labs,
or are they out of labs?
Fryzel: So the Documents List
API is actually in both--
version 2 is out of labs,
stable for 3 years,
and version 3,
we are actively developing it.
We're adding features
left and right,
and because of that, uh,
we haven't brought it
out of labs yet.
man: Great, thank you.
Fryzel: Yeah, pleasure.
Hello.
man: Hi, using Java API,
can we create labels?
Fryzel: I'm sorry--deletes?
man: Using Java API,
can we create labels, folders?
Fryzel: Can it integrate
with folders--the Java API?
man: Yeah.
Fryzel: Yes, uh,
the Java client library
implements every function
of the API,
um, so you would
essentially call, um,
you know, myclients.GetDocList,
just like I showed onscreen--
actually, the method is called
the same exact thing in Java,
but I showed a Python sample,
so...
man: Yeah.
Fryzel: There's a Java
developer's guide
you should definitely check out.
man: Thank you.
Fryzel: Yep. Hello.
man: Is there a way to get
the last modification date
for the access security
settings on a document?
Fryzel: For the access time?
man: Yeah, so if, uh,
an user's been added,
to tell if the ACL has changed?
Fryzel: The--so, uh,
talk to me afterward.
I'm--it's a little bit
complicated to implement,
but I'm happy to help you do it.
man: Okay, cool.
Fryzel: Hello.
man: Hi.
We use...
[speaking indistinctly]
to integrate with Google Docs
and synchronize files
with devices.
Fryzel: Yep.
man: So you are able
to have those files from the...
[speaking indistinctly]
from the device.
It works really nice, okay?
so the API works really well,
but the problem is that
we would like to know
if the local name
of the user had changed
without having to pull
the Google talk system
every time to know
if there is something new.
So is there a way to know
that the file has been changed?
Fryzel: Yes.
man: That there is a new file?
Fryzel: Yes, uh, the--
I think I mentioned this
in best practices--
the app edited date--
the last point here--
uh, this is provided for each
resource, uh, given by the API,
man: Yep.
Fryzel: So what you would do
is cache this date locally,
on your server
or in your application,
uh, along with
the resource identifier,
and if you noticed that
this date changed...
man: Mm-hmm.
Fryzel: You would know
that the file changed.
man: Yeah, but we have to pull
the servers to know that--
Fryzel: Yes. So, uh--
man: So there is a way to be
notified when something change?
Fryzel: Yeah, I'm with you.
So this goes back to a previous
question in which I said,
that is definitely something
we are considering,
uh, but I have no other
information at this time.
man: Okay.
Fryzel: Yeah. Sorry.
man: Thank you very much.
Fryzel: Any other questions?
Okay, thank you very much.
[applause]